[Música]
comienza en semanas decisivas para
ucrania las tropas de este país están
por recibir un lote de armamento pesado
que ha sido cedido por occidente de otra
parte el presidente de estados unidos
joe biden solicitó al congreso de su
país la aprobación de 33 mil millones de
dólares para ser enviados en ayuda a
kiev tal vez lo más destacado de esta
semana fue esa visita de antonio
gutiérrez el secretario de las naciones
unidas a la ciudad de moscú ya kiev para
bajar un poco las tensiones efecto que
por supuesto no ha sido evidente sólo un
día después putin el presidente de rusia
vladimir putin en su ya casi que
habitual amenaza semanal reiteró que si
algún agente extranjero interfiere en el
conflicto habrá represalias por parte de
rusia estas fueron sus palabras y
tiene la intención de intervenir en los
eventos en curso desde el exterior y
crear amenazas descontentos para rusia
que son necesarios para nosotros brillo
mínimo y plenas usted debe saber que
nuestros ataques de represalias serán
como un rayo
tenemos todas las herramientas para esto
cosas que ninguna otra persona para
vivir que tengo ahora si instrumento
nos adaptaremos y los usaremos si es así
y quiero que todos lo sepan no hemos
tomado todas las decisiones sobre el
asiento
importante también para destacar la el
corte de suministro de gas a polonia y a
bulgaria por no pagar sus cuentas al
kremlin en rublos rusos cumplió entonces
su palabra y estos dos países se
convirtieron en los primeros dos de la
unión europea en quedarse sin suministro
de gas ruso esto fue lo que dijo el
presidente ruso vladimir putin sobre
este tema ya que llegó vio muy atribuye
una grupo y bloqueamos el primer golpe
aplastante como lo creían en occidente
de sanciones ilegítimas contra nuestro
país nuestro sistema bancario la moneda
nacional el transporte el comercio la
economía en su conjunto las han
resistido y no se han derrumbado al
contrario ahora tenemos una buena razón
para el desarrollo
y lo previsto es un diestro y también
hay que hablar de lo que ha sucedido en
el puerto de gerzón en donde los son
rusos destituyeron al alcalde local y
convocaron a un referendo para votar a
favor o no de la independencia de esa
región la región de gerzón para crear
una nueva entidad llamada precisamente
república popular de gerzón que sería
algo similar a las regiones de don
jet-ski lugansk en la región del donbass
a esto también hay que sumar la
incursión en escena de un actor llamado
transnistria la región moldava prorrusa
separatista que tiene apoyo de moscú y
permite el acceso al oeste de ucrania a
través del río ni esther la atención
también ya se ha extendido hasta la
bencina moldavia veamos una torre de
radio que transmitía emisoras rusas
oficinas del ministerio de seguridad del
estado de moldavia y una unidad militar
todas fueron blanco de ataques con
explosivos entre el lunes y el martes en
la región separatista del país
transnistria nadie ha reivindicado la
autoría de los atentados pero la
presidenta de moldavia ha advertido
sobre cualquier intento de desórdenes en
el país
dyn informan el explicar el arte en
láchar hasta ahora por la información
que tenemos en este momento estos
intentos de escalada provienen de
facciones de la región de transistor ya
que son fuerzas pro guerra y están
interesados en desestabilizar la
situación en las regiones
de estabilice
mientras que ucrania culpa a rusia de
intentar desestabilizar la región
señalando al gobierno de vladímir putin
de conspirar para invadir el territorio
separatista la seguridad en moldavia y
su región de transnistria ha sido motivo
de preocupación desde que estalló la
guerra en ucrania ante el temor de que
rusia pueda intentar aprovechar la
autoproclamada región autónoma del país
para apropiarse de la zona de habla rusa
y crear un cinturón de control que vaya
de este a oeste
transnistria se separó de moldavia tras
una guerra civil a principios de los
años 90 y aunque su independencia nunca
ha sido reconocida 1500 soldados rusos
siguen estacionados en la región como
moldavia no forma parte de la otan en la
unión europea crece el temor de que
pueda estar en el punto de mira de rusia
pues hoy en el debate de france 24
hacemos balance y analizamos los hechos
recientes relacionados con la guerra en
ucrania y para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a iván killswitch él es
analista internacional e investigador de
la universidad de tartu estonia él es
polaco mexicano y se conecta
precisamente desde la ciudad de tartu
también está con nosotros fabián calle
politólogo y analista internacional
especializado en seguridad él se
encuentra en la ciudad de buenos aires
en argentina ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos los comentarios
y preguntas que deseen hacer lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram también en twitter estamos
como france24 guión bajo s arroba santi
logo que es mi cuenta personal le estén
recuerdo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas para
analizar este tema comienzo entonces con
iván dándole la bienvenida al programa
gracias por acompañarnos iván en esta
oportunidad y quiero comenzar hablando
con lo que precisamente comenzaba yo la
introducción de son esas amenazas por
parte del presidente ruso vladimir putin
tal parece que cada semana rusia amenaza
a la comunidad internacional de alguna
manera hace unos días veíamos al
canciller lávrov amenazado con la
posibilidad de un conflicto a escala
nuclear aunque para matizar un poco
decía que rusia eso nunca lo iba a
permitir pero dejaba ese sinsabor de
amenaza como interpretar estas palabras
del presidente ruso esa amenaza a un
posible agente extranjero que incursione
en escena en ucrania
donde todo hay que pensar en estas
amenazas como una
evidencia del et del hecho que ya se
encuentra desconectada de la comunidad
internacional un acto responsable o como
un actor
responde a las instituciones y las
normas internacionales de la manera que
otros países desesperados los países que
ahora mismo están operando según su
propia lógica militar con su propia
lógica antenista y estas amenazas son
solamente evidencias que ahora la lógica
de la de tomás y de las instituciones
internacionales no ha estado pegando al
menos no está operando como despegaría
de un país en tiempo de paz o con alguna
pegando con buenas intensificado y
fabián en la ciudad de buenos aires en
argentina cuál es su opinión sobre estas
declaraciones del presidente ruso esto
que ha sido considerado como una amenaza
para la comunidad internacional y como
lo decía yo prácticamente algo habitual
como parte de este discurso del kremlin
cada semana a emitir una amenaza
distinta al mundo
bueno lo del otro día en la número 24 de
uso de amenaza de uso de arma nuclear no
creo que no hay registro desde que se
inventó el arma nuclear en el 45 que se
haya repetido 24 veces en un lapso de
menos de 60 días luz la amenaza un uso
de arma nuclear yo creo que la base de
esto este rusia está trabajando sobre un
escenario que no era el previsto el 23
24 de febrero cuando esto se inició para
una guerra de 34 días
la huida de silencio su muerte y la
colocación de un gobierno afín a en
ucrania una desmilitarización
y después una fragmentación no
transformar ucraniano estado a salió un
estado disciplinado a rusia como
bielorrusia bueno no sucedió y entramos
en un escenario donde hay que empezar a
improvisar nos pasamos del escenario de
guerra relámpago a la guerra total
y la guerra total tampoco anduvo hubo
retirada en el norte rotura retirada en
el oeste concentración ahora en el este
y en el sur estamos en una tercera etapa
y en este en este clima de improvisación
estratégica es lógico que que algo que
no estaba previsto que era darle tiempo
occidente a otros aliados para meter
gran toneladas de armamento de
asesoramiento de inteligencia que no una
guerra de tres días no se hubiera podido
dar será creo que es una reacción
natural de rusia al ver que se tratan
formando ucrania en un arsenal y si lo
está enfrentando
fabián continuo con usted para hacer la
ronda de preguntas a la inversa y ya que
usted toca el tema de la estrategia
quiero hablar de esa parte que
mencionaba el reportaje previo a
comenzar el programa previo a comenzar
la entrevista en el que habla de ese
posible corredor que puede conformar
rusia desde la región de gerzón hasta la
región separatista moldava de
transnistria eso le permitiría a rusia
controlar prácticamente la totalidad del
sur de ucrania le permitiría también
controlar el puerto de odessa y empezar
a escalar hacia el oeste a través del
eln y esther de ese río que atraviesa
esa frontera entre ucrania moldavia y
pues esta región de transnistria eso a
nivel militar puede evidenciarse puede
de pronto
tomarse como una posibilidad desde la
parte estratégica usted cómo lo ve
a uno de los escenarios
alcanzables porque está operando en la
frontera con rusia es hacer las
conexiones del donbass la zona del mar
de azov
la caída de mario pool excepto la mega
fábrica donde hay todavía más de 3.000
soldados
ucranianos
en esa inmensa fábrica inmenso búnker
que rusia ha decidido no asaltar con
infantería si bien la sigue bombardeando
con aviones
son más de 10 kilómetros cuadrados de
fábrica que están todavía en manos de
los ucranianos pero pongamos que el
resto de la ciudad mario pool que da
acceso al al mar de azov está en manos
de manos de rusia yo creo que eso es
alcanzable creo que no es alcanzable la
toma de odessa
creo que le va a resultar extremadamente
difícil alejarse todo ruso la caída de
una ciudad de esa magnitud de ese tamaño
y que está crecientemente armándose
todos los días pero la conexión el
pedazo que falta de la zona de bombas lo
que no se controló
en el 2016 el 2014 perdón cuando se
produce ese esa adicción pues a la
separación de ucrania de sectores pro
rusos yo creo que es alcanzable y es
digamos sería insólito que rusia no lo
pueda conseguir porque está usando todo
su poder militar a pocas decenas de
kilómetros de su frontera si además que
es paradójico que allí en transnistria
hay cerca de dos mil soldados rusos
estacionados allí precisamente pedidos
por naciones unidas para garantizar la
paz en esa región tras ese conflicto en
1992-1993 resulta paradójico ver que
entonces pues a la luz de este conflicto
prácticamente ya habría tropas rusas en
ese territorio
está en el sur oeste de ucrania e iván
continuo con usted precisamente
preguntándole por esta región de
transnistria y moldavia hay temor
internacional y temor en la unión
europea
que las tropas rusas pasen de esta
región a una posible incursión militar
en moldavia un país que es muy pobre en
términos económicos su ejército no está
bien preparado y allí muchos analistas
dicen que una incursión militar sería
cuestión de días para que el gobierno
que es pro unión europea cayera y
moldavia quedara bajo
en posesión de los de los rusos como ve
usted allí en europa esa posibilidad de
que moldavia pueda verse involucrada en
este conflicto
la posibilidad está presente pues en
efecto la luz ya ha demostrado una
gestión
cuando
despidió este caso ocaña y del modo que
moldavia
con la costa del mar negro
moldavia y quería estar
y encima de eso moldavia en contraste de
buscar ya del país actualmente pequeño y
obtengo una gran población cierta
el gobierno mismo
en caso de la luz
verdadero desafío
pondría en riesgo sus productos
y
estamos teniendo problemas con su
conexión y no se entiende muy bien lo
que nos está respondiendo voy a dar unos
minutos para que la parte técnica pueda
solucionar este problema en la conexión
sin duda alguna moldavia cumple algunos
de los requerimientos que siempre ha
usado rusa russia como excusa para estas
incursiones militares es un país que
pertenece a la esfera soviética es un
país donde hay una alta población
rusoparlante o eslava también como ha
pasado para argumentar la necesidad de
entrar allí con tropas como pasó en el
donbass o como pasó una patria y en él y
en osetia del norte continuó entonces
con fabián en la ciudad de buenos aires
mientras arreglamos este tema el técnico
hablando de un chico con moldavia para
seguir abarcando temas destacados de la
semana y es en caso de una incursión
militar o de algún tipo de ataque o
hostigamiento digámoslo así por parte de
rusia moldavia que no es ni unión
europea ni de la otan
y la pregunta es quién podrá ayudar a
rumanía a perdón a moldavia podría ser
su hermano mayor rumanía
bueno si se mete rumanía estamos en la
tercera guerra mundial digamos porque
rumanía es miembro de la otan y tiene
que pautan tiene que pasar a ayudar a
rumanía
yo creo que le va a resultar difícil si
bien la diplomacia y las normas siempre
son un ropaje en la lucha por el poder
internacional
va a ser difícil que rusia pueda
justificar a un
manipulando el relato una invasión de
moldavia
primero porque ese país nunca pidió
aplicar al otan nunca pidió asistencia
militar masiva o no masiva occidente ha
tenido una política de buscarse llevar
bien con la unión europea y con rusia a
lo largo de estas décadas no ha habido
ataques de las reducidas fuerzas
moldavas a los sectores prorruso de
transnistria que se
independizaron de hecho ya en el año 92
por lo tanto no veo una incursión
militar masiva de
rusia moldavia lo que sí veo es una muy
posible declaración de independencia o
algo parecido a lo que se está haciendo
en la zona de bombas para sumar a ese
corredor que seguramente le va a dar a
rusia el control del mar de azov no del
mar negro porque para controlar todas
las costas al mar negro tendrían que
conquistar o de esa
y en el caso de querer controlar todo el
mar negro creo que rusia se compraría un
conflicto de muy muy largo plazo con
turquía turquía jamás aceptaría esto y
turquía gary a todos los recursos
diplomáticos políticos militares y de
todo tipo
con apoyo de otros países de occidente y
del medio oriente para complicarle mucho
la vida a rusia en el cáucaso siendo a
tu respuesta otra vez si transnistria se
puede declarar e independiente tropas
rusas e moldava y la invasión masiva por
ahora no lo veo por ahora no lo ven es
la opinión de favianca ya nuestro
invitado desde la ciudad de buenos
aires- iván en tartu estonia en pasó la
página a otro de los temas de la agenda
y es ese corte de gas a los dos primeros
países de la unión europea polonia y
bulgaria por no pagar las cuentas
pendientes con moscú en rublos rusos que
análisis hace usted de esta respuesta de
esta confirmación de esa advertencia que
había hecho el kremlin ya la unión
europea
este reciente desarrollo en la relación
entre rusia y bulgaria polonia se
encuentra dentro de la tendencia más la
vida de negocio usando sus recursos
energéticos
para fines políticos
eso ya fue evidente en años pasados
especialmente la relación con ucrania y
ahora lo vemos como el continuador de
una continuación de esta política con
los casos de polonia y bulgaria lo que
es bastante único es que
es en un contexto de alguna guerra pero
de una caída masiva es un contexto de un
colapso de las relaciones entre europa y
asia
en respuesta social e saturan ucrania y
encima de eso no estos usuarios de
manera muy
repentina por decirlo de una manera ya
hubo preparaciones para responder a un
tal corto del suministro de energía
pero no hay pero todavía están en marcha
los planes para reemplazar la energía
que no se ha obtenido por
parte de rusia
fabián mercados alternos quienes pueden
llegar a suministrar a estos dos países
que se quedan sin gas ruso tienen
reservas ellos lo han dicho tenemos
reservas para unas semanas considerables
pero quién podrá suministrarle gas a
turquía de apolo a perdón a bulgaria y
polonia
a ver primero que todo un comentario
general digamos rusia tiene que tener
mucho cuidado en también en
y mostrar como que no cumple los
contratos con europa europa es consume
el 90% de las exportaciones de gas ruso
por eso produce ha empezado con países
que consumen poco gas ruso no italia
alemánia que son grandes compradores del
estado ruso vive en gran medida de las
exportaciones de gas a europa occidental
por lo tanto esta es una vulnerabilidad
de los dos sectores no el gas ruso en
total en europa representa el 89 por
ciento del consumo de energía de europa
por lo tanto si bien en el corto y
mediano plazo es difícil de reemplazar
estamos hablando de 89 por ciento
no es algo es algo grave pero no es algo
catastrófico
si esos países tienen reserva porque se
han venido preparando desde fin del año
pasado de rusia ya venía mostrando los
dientes con respecto a lo de ucrania la
unión europea entre todos sus mecanismos
tiene mecanismos de ayudas o de
subsidios o de transferencia de de
energía y los mercados que se están
preparando para reemplazar en el corto y
mediano plazo a rusia argelia marruecos
egipto y eeuu con el creciente boom de
los barcos que transportan gas licuado
eeuu se está transformando y esta crisis
lo va a transformar todavía más en un
mega exportador de gas licuado y en
otros casos una revitalización de las
centrales nucleares de alemania va a
tener que replantearse sino tiene que
abrir las centrales nucleares creo que
rusia tiene que tener mucho cuidado
porque el reemplazo del mercado europeo
que se habla de que bazar china el
gasoducto a china como mínimo va a
tardar tres o cuatro años así que
durante tres o cuatro años el gas ruso o
se vende a europa o queda en los pozos
de rusia y al rusia no le entra plata
para más soportar una guerra y bancar su
aparato político militar
iván pasó a preguntarle ahora por otro
de los hechos destacados de la semana y
fue la visita del secretario general de
las naciones unidas antonio guterres a
la ciudad de moscú para reunirse con el
presidente vladimir putin y también en
la ciudad de kiev para reunirse con el
presidente selenski sorprendido se
mostró allí por los bombardeos en la
capital ucraniana y de los ataques que
ha habido a lo largo de las últimas
horas en diferentes puntos de ucrania
toda la delegación se mostró sorprendida
por estos hechos la diplomacia
nuevamente aquí intentando tal vez bajar
un poco el nivel de tensión
pero es más lo que se está jugando
naciones unidas- en este conflicto en
esta guerra por su incapacidad de acción
como evalúa usted el papel de este
organismo internacional que ha sido muy
criticado en este conflicto
al final las naciones unidos quieren
solo frente un rango de acciones que
disponen para tener un conflicto
internacional
una guerra de esta escala no ha sido el
objeto de una acción diplomática en
varias décadas
olvido lo que haga que sea lanzado con
su caña viola la ley internacional para
que vea que ucrania está luchando para
defender ese es el legítima y por lo
tanto la comunidad internacional se ha
expresado a favor de ucrania en varios
varias maneras y por lo tanto no decir
no es una sorpresa que naciones unidas
se demuestra
de mujer que expresó una visión
totalmente diferente que aquella que
rusia ha expresado en los últimos dos
últimas semanas al respecto de la guerra
que está llevando a cabo en ucrania
esto lo vimos muy claramente ahora en la
reciente visita de ejecutar esa ucrania
y ante todo con su entrevista con última
que sucedió recientemente también
y fabián su opinión sobre este tema
sobre el papel de naciones unidas está
este organismo en un punto de quiebre
sobre su importancia su verdadera
capacidad de acción ante estos
conflictos de importancia en diferentes
puntos del mundo pero específicamente en
este conflicto de ucrania y tal parece
que le ha faltado un poco de tracción le
ha faltado un poco de garra para meterse
para cumplir las funciones para la que
fue creada
a ver la onu fue creada para funcionar
cuando ninguna de las cinco potencias
con poder de veto tiene interés que no
funcione o no sea
siempre que uno de los cinco grandes
especialmente
grandes como el caso de eeuu o rusia son
parte del problema de las naciones
unidas es absolutamente impotente
digamos las naciones unidad fluye cuando
los cinco países con poder de veto y
dentro de esos los más poderosos
china-eeuu están de acuerdo en que
funciona así que no es sorpresivo lo que
sí creo que tiene un rol naciones unidas
es seguir preparando un eventual
escenario de posguerra de cascos azules
de ayuda humanitaria todo un trabajo que
va a ser muy necesario donde naciones
unidas tiene cierta legitimidad o alta
legitimidad para trabajar el proceso de
pago hacer una negociación entre rusia y
ucrania y atrás de ucrania eeuu esto va
a ser un diálogo en gran medida moscú
washington con quiebre en el medio
porque quien se ha ganado se ha ganado
el respeto
de las dos partes por cómo ha peleado y
cómo se ha manejado pero naciones unidas
no va a tener ningún rol relevante en
este proceso sí creo que es importante
que quede se vaya preparando el terreno
para para la posguerra y el rol que
puede tener naciones unidas- creando
ciertas zonas de divisiones entre la
fuerza a los dos países corredores
humanitarios
pero organizar el regreso de refugiados
para todo lo que naciones unidas puede
hacer cuando los cinco grandes en este
caso dos de los cinco grandes están de
acuerdo global
un escenario de posguerra pero es un
escenario que tal parece no está a la
vuelta de la esquina tal parece que ese
escenario puede llegar
en un tiempo a mediano plazo y esto lo
sustentó por esos armamentos y ese
armamento pesado que está por recibir
ucrania en los próximos días que daría
paso a una escalada de ataques por parte
del gobierno ucraniano en las provincias
del este del país por eso hablábamos al
inicio de este programa de semanas
decisivas lo que sigue ahora para
ucrania precisamente por ese
contraataque que va a hacer que podemos
esperar fabián con estos con este
panorama que nos pintan a muchos de los
analistas
y bueno acá tenemos una fecha clave para
putin simbólica y política que es el 9
de mayo él tiene que mostrar algo
los grandes que quería mostrar que era
la toma educarán en cuatro días no
tampoco la toma de ucrania en 20 días
tampoco creo que lo que quiere mostrar
ahora es el control de la zona este de
ucrania
tratar de atrapar en una bolsa a los
30.000 40.000 tropas ucranianas que
están combatiendo en bombas por eso está
haciendo un ataque de pinzas desde el
norte del sur de la zona este del país
mostrar el control del mar de azov
y con ese paquete modesto con respecto a
los planes originales
es decir que el objetivo siempre inicial
fue solamente el este y que eso se ha
cumplido
y eventualmente ahí recién
se puede abrir un espacio un espacio de
cierta pausa en este conflicto que
quizás la escalada bélica como la
podemos conoció en los últimos 60 días
en las próximas semanas se modere
después del 9 de mayo pero y vuelva a
aparecer en un tiempo
imprevisible porque este va a ser un
conflicto que nos va a acompañar muchos
muchos años para que nunca va a terminar
de digerir la pérdida de ciertos
territorios y muchas potencias turquía y
de lo tanto tampoco van a aceptar
fácilmente este nuevo status quo yo creo
que vamos a hacer un proceso de pausa en
la violencia
y eso se va a definir
básicamente en la batalla que se viene
las próximas semanas donde ucrania va a
tener cierta dificultad de trasladar
todo ese material pesado a la zona de
combate que es muy cercana a la frontera
rusa claver ucrania la parte de la parte
que ucrania va a quedar controlando que
es el 80 75 por ciento de su territorio
va a estar bien protegida y resguardada
de eventuales ataca rus
iván esta semana también fue destacada
noticia en los medios internacionales la
destitución del alcalde de la ciudad de
gerzón que es un importante puerto en la
desembocadura del río dniéper en el mar
en negro
veíamos también en los titulares como
los rusos que llegaron allí que
destituyeron al alcalde y querían
realizar un referendo para avalar una
supuesta independencia de esa región y
dejarla como una región similar a done
jets y lugansk como entiende uno que
este país invasor que está defendiendo
supuestamente unos valores y que
justifica esta invasión en un proceso de
desnazificación y de restitución de
valores supuestamente democráticos
pisotea un derecho democrático que fue
elegido un alcalde y fuera de eso pasar
por encima la constitución del lugar y
forzar una consulta ciudadana a la cual
se opusieron los ciudadanos y salieron a
las calles a rechazarla
pasando por encima y violando todos
estos derechos democráticos de los
ciudadanos es completamente
contradictorio la forma de actuar de los
rusos
en el sector y la la ocupación lo usa de
los nuevos territorios de estos
territorios que están ahora bajo una
nueva ocupación y uso del sur ucrania
específicamente
se encuentran bajo una
sagan
un muy severo régimen militar
el ejército de uso ha planteado varias
estructuras administrativas
han emplazado varias autoridades locales
a nivel de municipios o ciudades
pueblos con sus propios colaboradores o
a veces con gente que son implantados
desde afuera completamente por lo tanto
no hay
solamente una fachada hay un intento de
que a una fachada democrática o de
algún proceso legítimo de que ésta este
tipo de administración con la boya roja
y encima de ella que a él
acaso para una entidad separatista al
estilo de tu planeta si lugansk
pero en efecto no hay ningún tipo de
procedimiento no se está haciendo ningún
tipo de procedimiento que se conforme a
cualquier tipo de regla democrática o de
ley internacional o mucho menos su
genial
y van estas incursiones de rusia van
acompañadas de una maniobra que ha
utilizado rusia desde la época imperial
desde cuando existía el imperio ruso
cuando existió la unión soviética y es
la rusificación
forzar a los habitantes a hablar ruso
aprender el idioma
consumir televisión de este país la
historia y
prácticamente dejar de lado la historia
de el territorio donde se encuentran y
mirar siempre hacia rusia
en estos territorios donde ya de hecho
la población es de mayoría rusoparlante
la mayoría son eslavos y rusia continúa
con este tipo de políticas de
rusificación es parte de ese proyecto y
de esa oferta que ellos hacen al mundo
de un estilo de vida y de una forma de
ver el mundo a la rusa que todavía no
hemos podido entender y que también
vende en eeuu y china pero la cual es
ese estilo y cuál es esa oferta que hace
rusia un país bélico que invade a otros
territorios para anexarlos o para
desestabilizarlos o cuál es su impresión
no en efecto lo que estamos viendo en el
sur ucrania esos territorios bajo
ocupación el uso es los malos de juegos
de la época soviética o incluso de la
época del imperio de los sabes porque en
efecto
estamos viendo que museos de estadios
ucranianos son destruidos que
bibliotecas son destruidas que libros de
historia son quemados
se están abriendo clases y escuelas en
el idioma del uso con libros de texto e
instrucciones de negocio es un proceso
que no ofrece más a las personas bajo el
régimen de ocupación que decirles que no
existe tal cosa como ucrania que ellos
son miembros de la nación
en términos de valores o en términos de
d
y la promesa de un mejor bienestar
social solamente una
mal definida carga ideológica acerca de
valores conservadores están llamados
pero realmente se trata de que estado
personas en la cual acción personas
y fabián ya vamos llegando al final de
el programa tenemos ya pocos minutos
para cerrar con el último de los temas
que es la parte humanitaria y la
conclusión quería preguntarle
precisamente por la crisis humanitaria
ya la organización de naciones unidas
estima que para el final de este año
sean alrededor de 8 millones los
refugiados que salgan desde el
territorio ucraniano hacia los países
vecinos y de ahí salten a otros países
de europa o incluso en otros continentes
están estos países ya desbordados al
recibir tantos refugiados esta polonia
hungría eslovaquia moldavia rumanía en
posición de recibir a más personas
incluso ya han llegado hasta eeuu a
través de la frontera con méxico
a ver creo que la ventaja que tiene en
ucrania es que va a recibir una ayuda
masiva en lo económico todos los planos
va a ser algo creo que pocas veces visto
la unión europea va a usar toda su
chequera y eeuu a usar toda su chequera
por lo tanto creo que mucha de esa gente
que ha escapado del centro y del oeste
de ucrania van a volver obviamente va a
quedar una diáspora y creo que la gran
apuesta de occidente de la unión europea
de eeuu es que el 80 o el 75 por ciento
del territorio ucraniano que queda en
manos de ellos prospere se desarrolle se
mejore rápidamente la infraestructura
destruida y que el otro 20 25 por ciento
que quede en manos rusas si es que como
una versión 2.0 de berlín del este y
verdín del oeste no donde unos vivían
bien y los otros vivían mal creo que
vamos hacia un escenario de regreso de
mucha de esa gente
y un portentoso programa de ayuda
económica y lo plan marshall pero sólo
para un país
iván y cuál es su opinión en torno a
este tema
a estonia también han llegado muchos
ucranianos escapando de este conflicto
no es tal vez uno de los destinos más
habituales para ellos la mayoría ha ido
a la vecina polonia y algunos de ellos
han cruzado la frontera pie a moldavia o
a rumanía pero allí en estonia hay
capacidad para seguir recibiendo a más
refugiados cuál es el sentido allí en
este país
pienso que el sentido en estonia ha sido
una gran identificación con ucrania y
con el suplicio que está los ucranianos
están viviendo por lo tanto ha habido
una gran voluntad de ayudar a los
ucranianos de abrir las puertas del país
para esta población que es capaz de
ofrecer ayuda a los ucranianos que viven
que siguen en ucrania
no ha habido todo un esfuerzo
humanitario de organizaciones civiles
del gobierno de adaptar las
instituciones locales a las necesidades
de la población que llegue que está
llegando de malo que por el momento el
sentimiento que predomina al respecto de
los que llegan de los refugiados claro
sigue siendo una buena voluntad y deseo
de ayudarlos con su incapacidad para
hacerlo
iván y familiar les agradezco mucho por
este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24 muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros y ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]